l'écrivain rené maran année le 5
novembre
1987 la sénatrice marie laure phinéra
horth a choisi ce jour anniversaire pour
commémorer la mémoire du premier prix
goncourt obtenu en 1921 par un écrivain
noir avec son roman batouala une manière
de remettre au goût du jour un romancier
tombé dans l'oubli reportage réalisé par
nos confrères d'autres mères la première
un timbre l effigie de rené maran édité
à l'occasion du centenaire de
l'attribution de son prix goncourt 2009
121 le guyanais était né le 5 novembre
1887 c'est pourquoi la sénatrice marie
laure phinéra horth a choisi ces dates
pour commémorer son illustre compatriote
dans un des salons du sénat c'était
logique puis même pour mémoriser pour
que le citoyen lambda le guyanais puisse
retenir bas que il ya eu l'existence de
rené maran qui a obtenu le premier prix
goncourt noir il ya cent ans et je crois
qu'il fallait marquer les esprits et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
choisi exactement la date anniversaire
de rené maran où là il aurait eu cent
trente-quatre ans aujourd'hui où les
discours se succèdent est l'un des plus
surprenants nous apprend que la première
édition étrangère de batouala fut une
édition japonaise en 1922 puis je le
cite
brad wall a été interprété
comme une revendication des zones de
couleurs y compris les japonais est de
plus cette édition est ceinturé c'est ça
donc certaines phrases a été supprimée
par le pouvoir rené maran à manuel valls
tôt jusqu'à la fin de l'année les
manifestations mémoire de rené maran
vont se succéder
notamment le 14 décembre prochain c'est
la date à laquelle il obtint le goncourt
en 1921 pour vous